is there something to be said on a
philosophical level about the value of a
flawed robot
so like
the kind of robots you want is to be
partially flawed like do you think the
kind of robots will have in the home
that are friends and
um you know almost like pets wouldn't
they need to be kind of shitty because
we can love the somehow we humans love
the shitty I mean it is kind of
endearing and because I think it it kind
of I'm gonna mess up this world word
anthropomorphizes them
I think it's I mean I never feel as
deeply connected to my Roomba as when
it's like
I'm on a cliff like paper have you had
roomba's Tommy ledge no I really yeah
I've done that a lot yeah when they talk
to you yeah
and it it immediately anthropomorphize
them yeah and then you have if they have
a name which is why most roboticists
don't give names or gender to robots
because you become connected to them I'm
of the opposite mind
you should have like an intimate
relationship sounds weird but you should
have a close connection to robots I mean
there there's power in that there's a
social element of Robotics even an arm
I don't know there's something about us
humans that gain so much value
from our interaction with
Dynamic objects and we should like lean
into that as opposed to run away from it
that was always the confusing thing to
me about robotics
is that most roboticists run away from
that yeah
it's weird
because it's obviously going to be
robots are obviously going to be
everywhere yeah obviously but it's also
humans are sensitive and Squishy and
there's so much liability oh yeah
yeah but the humans are sensitive and
Squishy
when they interact with each other and
they hurt each other all the time
like sometimes they get together and
they're like oh you're the best you know
you're the best and then they leave each
other and then they break each other's
heart sorry about your breakups trying
to get over this I'm actually drunk for
this interview
I haven't been able to sleep
but
from a safety protocol perspective
people think about like physical damage
not emotional damage I know this sounds
ridiculous I know it sounds ridiculous
but it won't be it's already happening
there's an app called replica where
people have an intimate relationship
with an AI chatbot and they hurt
themselves I was thinking about this
yeah okay in dating what if you because
you can train
like a chat bot to kind of mimic the way
that you talk to people and interact
with people go on yeah but then I'm like
okay but what if we could all make AI
versions of ourselves and have them date
yeah like thousands of thousands of
other AI people and have that as a way
to turn out potential potential
candidates like I feel like that's gonna
be what's what's the
yeah what's the no but what's the point
of like meeting 20 people if you're like
oh but if we just had our AI versions of
ourselves in Iraq they'd be like oh your
your method of conflict is not going to
match or what if the AI version of you
like sleeps around with all the other
AIS and it becomes famous for that and
it starts its own only fans and then it
becomes and you're like what did you do
you come back home you'd realize like I
don't I didn't want to created a monster
create a monster I mean do I get a cut
exactly it's a question I'd be asked but
I think it's definitely like yeah the
the human technology interaction is
really interesting because I feel like I
don't love any of the machines that I
have in my life really if you haven't
you haven't I mean I don't love my phone
I touch it all the time and it's there
and it's like constantly it's a constant
presence but there's nothing in the meat
that feels like oh I love this object
like I kind of despise it
well that might be the way you show love
I don't know yeah that's a deeper that's
another psychoanalysis thing uh so you
know there's not robots whom you've
taken apart that you miss
no they're all terrible
I mean I I have objects that I built
that I love
um none of the robots I think but that's
also because it was a different that was
a different era where I wasn't really
putting a lot of care into the projects
I built so the more care you put into it
into the design to actually make it look
to make it functional and look good
that's where you put the love in yeah I
mean it is it's like I feel like any
technology company that figures out a
way to get you to actually genuinely
love your Roomba or like love it in the
way that you would love a pet
there's a lot to
be gained yeah and I think it's scary
depending on who the company is because
then they can manipulate you yeah if you
love your Roomba and all of a sudden
your Roomba starts telling you
to buy stuff yeah or it's leaving to put
lotion on Jeff basis's head yeah yeah I
don't know where the lotion came in but
yes maybe
I just imagine my Amazon Echo being like
hey hey Jeff Bezos is really a great guy
but even though you haven't do you think
it's possible to fall in love with the
robot yeah I mean people fall in love
with things all the time well people
have fallen in love with Yoshi robots
probably
I guarantee you there's people listening
to this that are a little bit
heartbroken saying that you've never
fall in love with your shady robots
they're like but I had a relationship
like an emotional connection to that
robot like the one with the parent Patsy
on the back oh that one that one I do
like I like that one a lot um that's
probably my favorite like shitty robot
can you explain it so it's the machine
it was my friend Daniel Beauchamp and I
we had this long-running joke about a
proud parent machine that you could give
a quarter and a pass you on the shoulder
says proud of you yeah
um so yeah I still have that hanging on
my wall in my workshop so that one I'm
I'm really happy with I just think it's
a really
funny concept and also I executed the
build well so that was so it's an arm
like what's the build yeah I built it
off of an old lamp arm yeah basically
it's just a motorized arm and this kind
of torso
of of a person so it's actually a hand
right correctly it's like a laser cut
it's just laser cut plywood and it kind
of has like it looks creepy yeah which I
like yeah the creepy helps with the yeah
and yeah it's as proud of you son
because I just thought that sounded more
funny than proud of you daughter and
also proud of you son just
it immediately communicates that it's
apparent it's not just like a collie or
something it's like proud of you
yeah oh my charges you a quarter for it
yeah but he added like chat GPT on top
of that and uh fine tune it on
conversations you've had with your
parents and all of a sudden you have a
thing that can fundamentally transform
your psyche yeah
that's all it takes that's a beautiful
creation how did you come up with that
creation I was my friend Daniel and I
who had a long-running joke about it
high level can you speak to your
creative process I think a lot of it I
mean it's changed for the Shady robots
yeah I mean it has a lot of overlap
um so it's identifying everyday problems
and in the shitty robot era I would kind
of take an everyday problem like oh I
have a hard time getting up in the
morning and I would solve it in the most
ridiculous spectacular way I could think
of so for waking up in the morning it
was having an alarm clock that slaps me
in the face with a rubber hand
and what I'm doing now is still
identifying everyday problems but I'm
actually trying to like product design
my way out of it what in your experience
was the funniest thing is it violence
like the hand slapping you food eating
is there is or is it just uh the
funniest
more like the proud parent machine
violent it doesn't
it's just emotional and it's kind of
a commentary on this fraught
relationship that we sometimes have with
our parents and their pride of us
sometimes every time sometimes my dad
visited like last week and he was like I
just want to say I'm so proud of you and
for the built life you built for
yourself and that was really sweet
yeah so put that on the back of my
autobiography too yeah it's not your
fault Simone
it's not your fault that stuff is my
fault
what was the longest one to complete for
the Shady robots that you remember
because he spent on a few of them you
spent quite a long time
foreign
which is also inspiring when you take so
long in a project yeah I think um
kind of in the more like fun Whimsical
Department rather than shitty robots I
built recently
um this music box so like a small music
box that kind of has a barrel with
little spikes and it plays the song but
I did a large version of that that pops
a sheet of bubble wrap and then like
plays tones into a pan flute so yeah you
can actually program it to play
different songs
that one kicked my butt in so many
creative ways that it was such a pain I
think that is probably the like
weird funny project that's taken me the
longest and like the biggest engineering
effort where's the all sound coming from
so if you it all came from me realizing
that if you pop bubble wrap and you pop
it right in front of the opening of a
pamphlet or like one of the pipes you
can have it play different tones
so that's what it does so I built this
music instrument off of that
okay if it's okay can you describe some
something like how it works some of the
the technical details here yeah so
basically I mean one of the big issues
that I had so I worked with
um as of a year and a half back I hired
an engineer stew so we were
collaborating on it
um but a big issue that we had was
feeding in the bubble wrap sheet and
like making sure that it feeds them
straight and doesn't get skewed because
you need to make like the popping feet
which is where you program this Barrel
to pop different bubbles need to be so
perfectly aligned on the bubble of the
bubble wrap for it to pop in the right
location so there's a feeder for the
bubble wrap that's a challenge and then
you have to have a barrel with a little
baby feet on it yeah that pops the ball
around that why is it so exciting that
Barrel was a pain as well I had to get a
like this rotary setup for my CNC and
yeah it was it was a lot of work
um but that was really fun and it's just
like
this is probably my
favorite
privilege of my job is that I can
go down any Rabbit Hole I think find
interesting did you have a lot of
Joy from popping the
I think I spent a week trying to figure
out the best material to pop bubble wrap
with because if you have two if you kind
of put them to to through uh or through
if you put a sheet of bubble wrap
through two rigid tubes the air kind of
just escapes from one side of the bubble
into the other so what I realized was
that if you have a squishy material like
kind of a yoga mat material in between
it it actually it prevents that and Pops
it a lot more reliably by like
increasing the pop reliability was a
huge effort as well you have to pop a
squishy thing with another squishy
because you don't need a lot of force
yeah like you just need it to not the
air to not be able to escape anywhere
wow but then also we had there was
different qualities of bubble wrap where
there was a lot of transference between
different bubbles so instead of the
bubble popping it would just seep the
air into a neighboring bubble and that
like membrane would kind of so you know
I I just like getting to spend weeks on
weeks of just studying bubble wrap did
you ever think about like publishing
academic work on Bubble Wrap no
wouldn't that be epic because nobody's
done this I bet you nobody's done
squishing it squishing material on
Squishy versus squishy
for popping I bet somebody has but you
know I I always I thought I was gonna go
into Academia like I was such an
ambitious student I loved school I I
actually applied to MIT but then I
pulled out because I was like no I don't
want to do it
um but now I realize it's really good
that I didn't because I'm too much of a
spouse too much of the spaz now I'm
distracted I'm thinking there must be
papers about when you have two bubbles
yeah you need to know the physics of two
bubbles when you have two bubbles
colliding
one will pop first
and there has to be good models of that
but that's very that has to do with
chemistry and whatever the uh the
material the ball was made from but then
no there's materials in here this guy
somebody must understand bubble wrap
deeply
like deeply
so I'm just gonna take a quick restroom
break because uh Lex is on his own train
now and I'm just gonna leave
yeah I actually don't need to go to the
restroom okay
so I'm going to insert like a two hour
uh instructional here with like a
Blackboard right it's the skill
the skilter it's I
throw you any top and you could just go
on about it I don't know if I have that
skill I just yeah
okay
um Bubble on bubble and interaction go
oh